the belt of debris just real quick
that's out there is there something
incredible to be discovered there
again we tend to focus on the planets
and the moons but it feels like
there's probably a lot of stuff out
there and it probably
what is it it's like a garbage collector
from
outside of the solar system isn't it
like doesn't it protect
from other objects that kind of fly in
and what
it just feels like it's a cool
you know you know when you like walk
along the beach and look for stuff and
like look for sure it feels like that's
that kind of place where you can find
cool cool weird things
or i guess in our conversation today
when we think about tools and what
science is
studying is there something to be
studied out there or we just don't have
maybe the tools yet or there's nothing
to be found
there's there's absolutely a lot to be
found so the material that's out there
is remnant material from the formation
of our solar system it's we don't think
it comes from
outside the solar system at least not
most of it
but there are so many fascinating
objects out there and i
i think what you've hit on is exactly
right that we just don't have the tools
to study them in detail
but we we can look out there and we can
see there are different species of ice
on their surface that tells us about
you know the chemical composition of the
disk that formed our solar system
some of these objects are way brighter
than they should be meaning they have
some kind of geological activity people
have hypothesized that some of these
objects have subsurface oceans
you could even stretch your imagination
and say some of those oceans could be
habitable
but we can't get very detailed
information about them because they're
so far away and so i think
if any of those objects were in the
inner solar system it would be studied
intently and would be very interesting
so would you be able to design a probe
in that like very dense debris field
be able to like hop from one place to
another is that just outside the
realm of like how would you even design
devices or sensors that go out there
and take pictures and and land do you
have to land to truly understand
a little piece of rock or can you
understand it from
remotely like fly up close and remotely
observe
you can learn quite a lot from just a
flyby and that's all we're currently
capable of doing in the outer solar
system
um the new horizons mission is a recent
example which flew by pluto and then
they had searched for another object
that was out there in the kuiper belt
any object that was basically
somewhere that they could deflect their
trajectory to actually fly by and so
they did fly by
another object out there in the kuiper
belt and they take pictures and they do
what they can do and if you've seen the
images from
that mission of pluto you can see just
how much detail we have compared to just
the sort of reddish dot that we knew of
before
so you do get an amazing amount of
information actually from just
essentially a high speed flyby it always
makes me sad to think about flybys
that we might be able to we might fly by
a piece of rock take a picture and think
oh that looks pretty and cool
whatever and that you could study
certain like composition of the surface
and so on
but it's actually teeming with life and
we won't
be able to see it at first and it's
sad because you know like when you're on
a desert island you wave your hands and
the thing flies by and you're
trying to get their attention and they
probably do the same
well in their own way bacteria probably
right but
and we we miss it i don't know some
reason it makes me it's a
it's the fomo it's fear of missing out
it makes me sad that there might be life
out there
and we don't we're not in touch with it
we're not talking yeah well
okay uh a sad
pause uh russian philosophical pause
okay
you